being great is doing something that no  one can do but also accumulate  highlights that will always look at best  show I've ever seen is the chip from Ty  gain 16 I was trying to get the ball  right in this world light spectrum I was  coming through there of course it has to  hang on a bit suspense it goes in place  bananas  have you seen anything like that pitch  shot from behind the green was one of  the greatest I've ever seen anyway once  overall I liked his tired he might as  well make it  nothing surprised me Tigers greatest  weapon had to be a his ability to make  that clutch putt when he had to you're  like oh hell do you make that  but it's Tiger you can't even count on  your hand Tommy  I hit it look pretty good it is better  than most  and then I start seeing a snap  I was a pretty sweet fly he'd built for  a month he'd go for a year now do it for  a decade that's what's up for its  greatness  [Applause]